this house in Beirut is where Carlos
Cohen is believed to be holed up now
arguably one of the world's most famous
fugitives sought by police in Japan and
Turkey the subject of an Interpol red
notice and a global media frenzy his
escape has embarrassed authorities in
Japan we're gone had lived under house
arrest and strict bail conditions
including a ban on overseas travel media
reports say these surveillance cameras
show him simply walking out of its Tokyo
home on Sunday he didn't return the
former head of o'connell nissan car
making alliance and a giant in the
global auto industry he was first
arrested in 2018 he was facing trial on
charges of financial misconduct
allegations he's repeatedly denied his
escape spanned three continents and
plenty of mystery bone contains he was
fleeing political persecution a turkish
company m ng jet says going took a
charter flight from Osaka to Istanbul
and another from there to his childhood
home Beirut Joe pointed on its understoo
that there's an entry to Lebanon after a
transit through Turkey from Japan the
following is very important it is
understood that there was a transfer in
the cargo department at the airport in
Istanbul M&G says an employee falsified
flight records so Goins name didn't
appear five people have been arrested in
Turkey accused of human trafficking
gaun has tried before to evade attention
by dressing as a workman when leave in
custody and March in his blog lawyer
Takashi Takano seen here with the beard
says he felt betrayed by Carlos goings
escaped but not by going himself instead
the Japanese legal system going had been
barred from seeing his wife and what
Takano called a violation of human
rights and another lawyer says 'gone was
being spied on
Carlos Cohen is promising to tell his
side of the story this week
Alexei O'Brien al-jazeera well Jacob
Wilson is a an investigative journalist
at The Daily Beast and we can talk to
him now in Tokyo
Jake welcome to the program it is an
extraordinary story isn't there to
vanished under 24-hour surveillance
ramifications over his escape absolutely
widespread as to how the escape was
facilitated what do you reckon well I
mean I think that bone is mr. gun has
been in Japan for a very long time so he
knows that at the end of the year Japan
in turns New Year's mode which is
probably the most important holiday
season year so that there would be very
few people watching him so if he was
going to escape this was the time and he
had been sort of preparing including
taking lessons in the martial arts and
seeing a physical trainer so he was
ready to run and I don't blame him I
don't think he was escaping just a
political persecution he's escaping a
system in which you only have a 1%
chance of winning um it's a very broken
system there will be many there in Japan
he will perceive that gun is cheating
justice and it's certainly very
embarrassing for for Japan itself and
not least Kniffin to well release on
this is a huge headache because you know
as long as dawn has been shut up they
don't have to deal with their own
problems with their own questions of why
they did this in the first place they
think about this you could have just
fired Carlos well why does Nissan go to
the prosecutors and make a plea bargain
to put Carlos Cone in jail and why do
they consult with the prime minister's
lawyer to do it um it's a very odd thing
to do in four
what is a you know a negligent well not
a negligible but a a financial crime
that's very dubious in the first place
how will this know it's gonna say how's
this case played out in the court of
public opinion and certainly the latest
development you know there is there is a
word that it's very popular it's
trending in Japanese media call now
called Ochoco kameen which means the
upper-class and Carlos Khan's case has
been trotted out again and again as a
case of selective justice meaning the
people Tokyo Electric Power Company who
were responsible for a nuclear disaster
that damaged the lives of thousands
they weren't prosecuted the people talk
of the airbag who made defective
products that killed people weren't
prosecuted and people are wondering why
does Carlos go and get this heavy-handed
treatment so you know in in many ways
there's kind of a sort of snickering
reportage of kind of like well you get
what you deserve for doing this crazy
case in the first place
alright what about now what now for for
Carla's gonna life as a fugitive kenny
rest happy in lebanon do you think he is
a problem in lebanon because there's a
the president of a nissan he went to
israel which is against the law in
lebanon to my understanding and that may
come back to haunt him but i think
generally speaking lebanon has no desire
to hand him over to the Japanese
authorities and in fact they asked for
him to be tried in Lebanon where he
might actually have gotten a fair trial
interesting well it's great to get your
perspective on this it's a fascinating
story a Jake Adel stone talking to us
there from Tokyo thanks very much indeed